this is the main water pipe to the
lebanese capital it's damaged and taps
have run dry in hundreds of thousands of
households for nearly a month
opposition member of parliament ibrahim
namely is at the site to find out why
the repairs are taking so long
an economic crisis has led to the near
collapse of state institutions but many
accuse successive governments of
mismanagement
what we try to do is put pressure on the
political uh
parties who are in the
ministry as possible for the
for maintaining the pipeline to solve
the crisis where we once and for all we
need really proper planning i mean you
cannot find that a city like beirut is
dependent on a single line
tankers are delivering water all over
the city a vital resource to households
already struggling with poverty and
inflation
every two or three days we have to buy
water that cost around 70 dollars people
need water to wash and clean and for
their bathrooms
water shortages are not new not enough
was invested in maintaining the network
since the end of the civil war in 1990.
it's been a year since the united
nations warned the public water system
in lebanon was on the verge of collapse
and that 71 percent of the population
around 4 million people could lack
access to water
but dilapidated infrastructure isn't the
only problem
the sector depends on the state for the
electricity that operates the pumps
money is needed to
purchase fuel to compensate for lack of
electricity fuel to run diesel
generators
also money is needed to stock up
the stores for with spare parts to
address any breakdowns the third is to
pay for
salaries
for workers that come to work every day
water authorities acknowledge that
merely repairing the pipeline won't
solve the problem the state is nearly
bankrupt and the government is failing
to implement the reforms necessary to
qualify for international financial aid
the big problem is when we don't have
electricity and no money to buy diesel
that means we can't pump water
few expect water services to improve
anytime soon in a country where the main
pipeline to the capital was last
serviced half a century ago senator al
jazeera beirut